You're telling a friend an amazing story and you just get to the best part...
...when suddenly, he interrupts, "The alien and I, not me and the alien."
Most of us would probably be annoyed,...
...but aside from the rude interruption, does your friend have a point?
Was your sentence actually grammatically incorrect?
And if he still understood it, why does it even matter?
From the point of view of linguistics,...
...grammar is a set of patterns for how words are put together...
...to form phrases or clauses, whether spoken or in writing.
Different languages have different patterns.
In English, the subject normally comes first,...
...followed by the verb and then the object.
While in Japanese and many other languages,...
...the order is subject, object, verb.
Some scholars have tried to identify patterns common to all languages,...
...but apart from some basic features, like having nouns or verbs,...
...few of these so-called "linguistic universals" have been found.
And while any language needs consistent patterns to function,...
...the study of these patterns opens up an ongoing debate...
...between two positions known as prescriptivism and deprescriptivism.
Grossly simplified, prescriptivists think a given language...
...should follow consistent rules, while descriptivists see variation...
...and adaptation as a natural and necessary part of language.